i signed up to the judo fanatics best of
uh oh no is there something that stands
out to you about him that's especially
you find beautiful like or powerful
about his technique
um
his adaptability to the situations and
understanding of
like what needs to happen in order to
throw these people
i specifically watched a match
with his and i was gonna do a breakdown
video on it because
is there a match do you remember what it
is it's him versus uh
garvey of
hungary um is he good at gripping so
we're watching the match against hungary
uh so the one minute comes so right here
coming up i've heard he's freakishly
strong i've never had the ability to to
train with him so i'm not
obviously looks super skinny
but but when you see him without his key
jacket on like
he's a jack dude
which is
uncharacteristic of a japanese player
from back in the day
in a way changed all that he was like
we're gonna get physical to compete with
the europeans that's another one of the
greats right and yeah he doesn't get
mentioned enough
and he's a righty here yeah
okay
and this is where he starts setting it
up it's like you can see he was standing
in like a left-handed stance and then he
changes
yeah so he grips almost like a double uh
uh double sleeve not a double sleeve but
the tricep the tricep and the the front
sleeve standing like a lefty
and no body grip just correct tricep and
sleeve and it was like the the biggest
whip
and twist of it of a new chamada
yeah he doesn't actually lift him off
the floor yeah and if you look at it in
like slow motion almost
um
yeah let's yeah there we go
um
the hungarian player was like a hundred
percent defense and he still did this
right so
right here like press pause
this this is like
an identifier if you're trying to like
learn judo and figure out how to set it
up
because knowing how to get to the point
right before you pull the trigger is
probably the most important
so when we watch this play out what
ono's going to do is he's going to pivot
off his right leg right here
he's going to backstep with his left and
it's going to pull um garvey's front leg
all the way forward into what we would
call like a neutral square stance
so he plants hard
and look at there's an interesting pull
with the track oh no it's not trying so
he almost like he starts with the tricep
and he like collects the gear or
something like that but it's still above
the elbow because you can see the bend
right
and right here see how he never put back
it up a little bit
that
this is kind of like one of those things
yeah pause it right there
so when he puts his right foot down he's
pulling so hard with his back
that when ono goes to put his left foot
down it never touches the mat
but by putting his left foot back
it actually pulls him garvey's foot
forward and so he's able to speed up his
throat by just continuing that motion
back yeah which what was supposed to
have been a step
turned out to just
in the middle of the action he makes a
split-second decision before putting the
foot down to just continue yeah because
he recognizes that feel in his hands
yeah and so it's like it never it's a
swing like he never touches the ground
but it never it never started as like a
big swing to a back step yeah he changed
his mind part way through so it's right
there
right yeah and then he goes nope he's
bringing that foot forward i'm just
going to go for it and wait is he full
like full air
look at that
boom boom and look at if you go a few
more steps forward right there his hip
is the same height as um garvey's
shoulder yeah
because he's leaning so far into the
throw with his body weight
and he's allowing that tricep grip to
rotate that's going to draw and guard me
forward
and now when you pause it right here
you think about the shear physics to
like get your body into this position
jimmy and i were so like when we saw
this for the first time we tried to just
stand like that and we couldn't do it
his
left foot is pointing straight ahead
his chest is perpendicular to that foot
or parallel with it right and his head
is by his foot yeah is that only
possible in the midst of a throw do you
think he works on making like i think
he's done
this particular throw not this style of
it but uchimada so much yeah that his
body has adapted to be able to do this
so when people are trying to learn and
like break down videos yeah they don't
understand like
the power he has and what
we call end range motion
yeah look at that so like look at the
full range of motion he takes right yeah
that left foot swings all the way around
and the torso starts
like at three o'clock and it goes all
the way around
like almost back to the three o'clock
yeah like like like that what it and he
never lifts his leg above his hip
and the crazy part is he never fell over
during any of it yeah look at that
stayed on his feet
what's he doing
is that is that a matter of pride or
just
i think that's just habit
the way the forces work like he can just
stay up
i that's one of the most beautiful
throws i've ever seen
there's so much wrong with it
but it worked it worked because when you
think about remember what we talked
about the very beginning like he's got
to get his center of gravity under his
wow well here's one of the top players
in the world throwing another top player
in the world with his hip at that guy's
shoulder height and it's still working
it's
okay so he this generation he could be
the great yeah and like he switched a
lot of those
details of the throw in the middle in
the middle and that that only is that
means he's probably what like a hundred
thousand times that throws happen
you